hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that was played yesterday in
the chess24.com uh speed chess
championship uh it's a game between
levan aaron and yanipanishi
and it's a part of uh well basically
it's a three-part competition first you
play a five plus one game then a three
plus one game not one game
several games as many as you can play in
the given time and then
one plus one games so like like bullet
but you have a plus one second
and i don't know which time format this
game is from
i think it's uh from from it's i think
it's definitely from the blitz section
so it's definitely not from the bullet
section or maybe it is but i don't think
it is
uh so if any of you do know uh do do
share
in the in the comments but i think it it
is from the blitz section
so without further ado uh let's check it
out uh s11 has the white pieces and he
opens
with e4 uh we have c5 by nepo he goes
for the sicilian defense knight f3 d6
and the d4 so a nice open sicilian
captures captures and now knight to f6
setting up
everything for for the night or we have
knight to c3 and
a6 the knight of variation of the
sicilian is on the board
uh we have f3 and e5 now that's not an
e5 so e5
uh kicking the knight back and then now
uh knight to b3
uh with bishop to e6 continuing
development and
11 does the same we have bishop to be
bishop to e3 and
knight to c6 now preparing to bring the
rook into the game the queen into the
game and uh hopefully
let's uh start uh pushing that pawn on
the queen side
uh we have queen to e2 and now comes
knight
to e7 and this is actually a new move in
the position uh some of the moves that
are known here are bishop the e7 just
preparing the castle and also knights to
a5
uh trying to trade off the uh a pair of
knights here however knight
the e7 is a new move uh and it's very
odd that it's a new move but it seems
like this is uh
some line that's not played very often
and it it it really makes sense since
all of the black's pieces now are aimed
at uh
just executing d5 which is definitely uh
what you have to do when playing uh
playing the night or so here we have a
queen side castle
and black now goes for d5 so the
downside of this
immediate 97 d5 is that your king will
be stuck in the center of the board
uh but as this is uh not a classical
game uh nepo doesn't mind so here we
have a capture
uh well sort of a small capture fest on
the e5
e captures knight e capture some d5
knight captures and
knight knight captures and the knight
captures and here
a nice prophylactic king to b1 we have
queen to c7
and now of course you want to bring the
rook into the game uh
bishop to c1 since there will be
constant pressure of this uh
knight captures here probably rook will
come to see it there's going to be
pressure on c2
and you don't want to constantly have to
calculate what happens if knight
captures on e3 so you could retreat it
to f2 you could retreat it to c1
uh here 11 retreats at the c1
and now comes bishop to e7 we're not
going to overanalyze anything since this
is a blitz game
and queen to e for now putting pressure
on the knight here if black isn't
careful
rook captures here is coming so we can
even show that if castles you can just
give up the rook for two pieces which is
of course
much better for white so instead after
queen to e4 we have rook to c8
and now black is trying to trick white
and it's actually a very nice trick
because it seems like
uh the uh there's no threat of checkmate
but
if you go for this captures captures and
captures there's queen captures on c2
and now after king to a1 you just give
up the queen for checkmate queen
captures on c1 and after the queen is
accepted
rook captures on c1 is checkmate so nepo
has to constantly be aware of this
and he plays uh sorry 11 and he plays c3
so now the c file uh is sort of out of
commission
uh at least unless and unless it's not
at some point you might play b5 b4 and
bust open the position but for now
uh white is somewhat somewhat safe so
here f5
pushing back the queen and now queen to
a4 with
check nepo retreats with king to f7 now
the king is very safe here you can bring
another rook into the game
and bishop to d3 now and here uh nepo
has a very very interesting idea however
uh it's a it's a very quick game you
don't have a lot of time to calculate
everything
and he played the rook h to d8 however
b5 was
incredibly strong here just giving up
the a6 pawn
or rather you you're not giving it up
because white really can't accept it
white has to play something like
queen to a5 and then uh black is going
to move the queen not
trade of course and uh will continue
attacking because if you accept the pawn
uh then black just gets too many tempe
attacking the white queen for example
queen captures
uh you develop the other rook as well
and now after a queen trade is offered
just queen to a7 threatening the a2 pawn
and if you defend let's say a3 now comes
rook to c8
and it's just game over uh whatever you
play you have to move the queen
somewhere you can just capture on c3
captures rook a to b8
and there's just too much pressure white
white is just getting destroyed here
so after b3 b5 would have been very
interesting but okay rook h to d8
nepo continues developing and now comes
queen to a5
offering a queen trade and of course
nipple declines we have queen to c6 he
wants the
uh he wants to attack this game not
trade queens
uh and white also has to do something so
here
g4 hoping to open up uh the g file
uh and now g6 with captures captures now
the g
file has been opened and rook h the e1
now uh first putting pressure on the e5
pawn but nepo just says okay there's
always time to defend it bishop to f6
and now comes bishop to c2
so what do you what do you do here uh
here uh
nepal finds a really really strong move
and he plays the b6 and now
uh what can levin do uh the you don't
really have all that many good squares
for the queen
queen to a3 can come but then just uh
you know
pawns are pawns are marching forward so
instead he captures the pawn
but now comes knight to b4 and the queen
is under attack you have to do something
about this
we have queen all the way back to f1 uh
there are no
better moves uh if you go for let's say
queen to a3 now then just
knight captures on c2 followed by rook
to a8 is extremely strong
so uh you go all the way back queen to
f1 and now comes
knight captures on c2 forcing the king
to come back to the c
file king captures and the queen to a4
now pinning the knight here and also
preparing to capture the a2 pawn
and here we have queen to h3 uh here uh
11 says okay you captured eight upon i
don't really care i want to capture on
h7
and just uh gain a a counter attack here
but
however uh the white is completely lost
here and uh not only lost
black actually has a forced checkmate in
seven moves
uh which is not why we're uh you know
analyzing this game because
uh well the title says differently
however feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this winning idea
while i uh give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
the forcing sequence and
you know without staring at the ceiling
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's
rook captures on c3 this is how it
starts and
now the point is uh the well the rook
just cannot be accepted because if the
king captures
queen c4 is made in one so obviously
that's not the mate and seven we were
discussing
uh but if b captures on c3 then we get
queen captures on a2 the king of course
has nowhere to go as the rook covers the
entire d
file bishop has to block and now comes
bishop captures
on b3 and now the two bishops are too
powerful king to c1
bishop to g5 check ends the game you
have to block and then bishop captures
on d2 a nice double bishop checkmate
so that's not possible you cannot
capture with the king you cannot capture
with the pawn
even though uh when i say it's made in
seven that means it's mating seven with
the absolute best possible defense that
lasts the longest
however after king to b1 now it's a
different story so feel free to pause
the video once again
and find the movie as this is the
position from the thumbnail
well i'll give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
the awesome queen sacrifice and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's uh sorry it's queen captures an a2
just queen captures an a2 and that's it
only one move for the king
king captures and now comes bishop
captures and b3
with check and now the king has a few
options you could either go
uh to the back rank and it's uh
it's pretty much the same uh either
bishop to c2 followed by rook to a8 or
the other way around
depending on what the white king plays
for example if king to a1
first you're gonna check with the rook
and then after king b1 just bishop the c
to checkmate
but it's also extremely interesting what
happens after this bishop captures on b3
check what if king the a3
then you play bishop the e7 check again
the two bishops are simply amazing here
and there is no move the light square
bishop covers these squares the bishop
covers this and
checks the king so you'd have to block
with the rook only move and now it's
bishop captures on d6 so nothing
nothing to be done here however after
king to b1
uh nepo does not find rook queen
captures on a2 rather he plays a
different move he
he prepares it with rook to a8 which is
incredible
uh but uh you know i always say it's not
the moves that were played but also the
moves that weren't played that make the
game
very interesting so here nipple went
rook to a8
and now comes a queen captures on h7
here nipple allows a few checks but he
knows that it's only four
for fun with bishop to g7 queen h5
checking the g8 and now
no more useful checks so here uh before
capturing on c3 and allowing this
capture first uh
dislodging the rook from a8 so rook to
d8 with check
you have to capture because the queen
covers the squares so rook captures and
not only now
b captures on c3 but nepo just brings
back the rook rook to a8 again
threatening to pick up the a2 pawn and
now rook
e2 defending we have queen to b5 now
attacking the rook and
rook to b2 now putting more pressure
uh here although rook to g2 here would
have been
uh probably enough for a draw it's hard
to say because it's of course a very
quick game
and a lot of things would happen but if
this was a normal game if you were just
talking about the position then rook g2
with
with pressure along the g file should be
enough for
for white to get a draw here uh but rook
the b2 was played and now
nepo just goes for it uh queen to d3
with
track king to a1 and now queen to d1
uh so again what do you play here uh you
the
the threats are you know all over the
place you can just eliminate the
defender of the bishop so that's one
option
uh so here rook the b1 actually fails
miserably to queen the c2 threatening
checkmate and now after you block this
you can just go rook captures on a2
that's enough and after king captures
just queen captures on b3 followed by
queen to a2 checkmate
so after queen d1 uh we have queen to g5
now defending the bishop this way but
now uh nipple just played bishop
captures on b3
and it was in this position uh on move
36 that 11 arjan resigned the game
so yeah only 36 moves but we've actually
covered quite a lot of lines for a blitz
game so
you know sorry about that unless unless
you enjoyed it but yeah you don't really
have anything here
the bishop cannot be captured because
just queen captures on b3
and you know there's nothing white can
do checkmate is coming
you can block it for the moment like you
could play something like queen here
but uh that's just uh you know
prolonging the inevitable you're down a
rook and i mean
black's moves are just too simple so
here after bishop captures on b3
11 resigned and a wonderful victory for
iannipomnishi who did not
finish the game as we hoped he would
after king to b1 he did not find uh
queen captures on a2
but that's where you guys come in and uh
of course all of you found queen
captures on a2
uh so yeah uh that's uh that's the game
i do hope you guys enjoyed it uh it's
from the uh speeches championship like i
said and even though nepal won such a
such a wonderful game it was actually 11
who won
uh the the clash and uh
it will be levin who uh you know
proceeds further in in the competition
so we're gonna see uh who wins next uh
it will be mvl versus uh versus iron man
uh and carlson will be waiting for a
winner
between uh in the match between artemiev
and anish geary
so we'll he we'll see what happens there
and what happens on the other side of
the
table and then you know who who emerges
at the top is going to be very
interesting
uh but yeah once again i do hope you
guys enjoyed it uh sorry about again the
longer analysis of a blitz game but you
know it just
it just happens you know it's it's not
uh like i'm planning it
uh i would like to thank three mystery
people for a contribution to my channel
uh or
also uh carl dyder who specified that
his last name
rhymed with spiders so thanks for that i
i wouldn't guess that
uh so you know that's uh always nice to
have to have an insight uh and uh abdul
moshe al-raji for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world uh or doesn't happen such
as it didn't in this game here so thank
you
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day